[Musique]
vous avez cette occasion unique d'être
le premier d'entre nous à entrer dans le
prochain siècle
personne au monde ne peut approcher un
tel niveau de réalisme dangereux c'est
incroyable je sais pas quoi penser de ce
concept c'est la minurso vif mais robot
feront toutes les choses que vous leur
demanderez bonjour sophy
ne laissez pas ce robot évoluer trop
émotionnellement et trop rapidement
contre 11 ça derrière stressé mjx
pourquoi vous me demandez ça je peux
peut-être vous aider je vous aime bien
et si vous le traitez comme une personne
il pourrait se comporter comme tel
qu'est ce qui vous fait sourire voir que
vous êtes heureuse s'il devait y avoir
un problème quelconque henry est
programmé pour revenir à sa cabine de
réglages et se réinitialiser qu'il vient
de problèmes peuvent survenir des
problèmes d'ordre secondaire
mairie
où suis-je ce qui est en train de rêver
je rêvais que j'étais un animal
visiblement il répond à tout ce que tu
leur courage à mr
[Musique]
vous ressentez le désir sensuelle
voulez vous que je puisse leur sans dire
parce que ça fait de vous une personne
fermé les yeux alors arrête
immédiatement ce que tu fais avant qu'il
soit complètement détraqué c'est
peut-être vous qui devriez changer
[Musique]
je vais résoudre ça tout de suite
il est tout de suite dans votre cabine
de réglages
pas question je n'irai pas